I feel like it is so funny
when women wanna prove that they can do what men can do.
And to me, it is so funny because I'm like, no, thanks.
Do I wanna change the oil in my car?
Absolutely not. Like, no.
Do I wanna do a car wash?
No. Do I wanna change a tire?
Absolutely not.
Like, those are things
I don't even wanna prove to you that I could do that,
because even if I could,
I don't wanna do that.
I'll be inside taking care of the babies,
baking bread,
making food,
cleaning the windows,
like, laying outside on a hammock.
I'm sorry, but it's just funny.
Like, it's not a flex.
And to me, us as women
already being able to carry babies,
like, have a.
Be pregnant, um,
just be able to, like,
have. Use our hands to cook and make bread
and make food delicious
and nourish our families and nurture babies. Like, to me,
that is such a wonderful gift that I don't even look at,
like, oh, as we
as women cannot do,
change a tire or whatever.
Like, I don't even look at that
because we already have such a wonderful gift
as women that god gave us that.
Why would I focus on what I can't do?
Like, I'm gonna focus on my god given gift
and I'm gonna embrace that.